how do mommies walk is this a zombie
mummys also like well guys I told you
last week that I was going to be a mummy
I was not joking I'm gonna be a mummy
and I'm gonna be dressed up as a mummy
for Halloween and Halloween is like my
favorite holiday of the year so I'm
really excited because I'm gonna be
sharing some recipes today that me and
my little pumpkin totally adore so I've
got not one but I've got two awesome
vegan and gluten-free treats that you
and your kids are going to love we're
gonna be making my blood and guts
chocolate cups and for a little healthy
snack we're gonna do my apple and Anand
butter alien smiles guys look at me look
at me on the honest I'm a crazy alien
smile treat obviously I just moved you
way more excited to make these snacks so
I figured we gotta get right into it
let's do it
first up my blood and guts chocolate
cups
[Music]
I start by melting some dairy-free dark
chocolate and some coconut oil over some
simmering water until it's all nice and
smooth and melted down then I add my
melted chocolate to some silicone and
baking cups and I like to use a
combination of my big baking cups
because hey sometimes you need a big
tree I also like to use some of these
little mini ones because sometimes you
just need a little something song to get
you through
then I place these in the freezer for
about 15 minutes until they're set up
and frozen now it's time to work on our
filling I add some fresh raspberries to
a saucepan and let them simmer until
they break down and get you a nice Jam
consistency then I add some chia seeds
and pomegranate arils give it a good
stir and place it in the fridge for
about an hour to set up now it's time to
fill I add a generous dollop of my chia
gem to the center of each of my cups
making sure that of course I don't fill
them up all the way can we still need
leaving some room for some extra
chocolate
then I top them off with more of that
luxurious melted chocolate making sure
to get all around the edges and on top
as well cover that filling
[Music]
then I place them back in the freezer
until they're all set up pop them out
one by one
and look how cute for those look hey
don't worry about some of the blood and
guts spilling out that's where the fun
happens top it off with a little bit of
flaky fleur de sel and joy
[Music]
next my Aqualand Fahmy butter alien
smiles
to assemble our aliens I start with some
slices of granny smith apple and i add a
little bit of natural almond butter onto
the inside edges of the apple
punks the bottom half add a little
strawberry tongue and on both sides
I add some cute little sunflower seeds
for our teeth next I put a little dot of
dark dairy free chocolate onto some
vegan marshmallows and let that dry just
for a second then we put it all together
I put the top hop of the Apple onto the
bottom half and I insert two little
toothpicks
[Music]
pop on your little alien ice and enjoy
[Music]
well guys me and my little alien smile
had so much fun sharing these awesome
vegan and gluten-free Halloween recipes
with you if you love these recipes be
sure to give it the thumbs up leave me a
comment below with some of your favorite
Halloween recipes what do you want in
this Halloween and subscribe to the
channel ll see you next time on Abby's
kitchen bye
[Music]